is the love of nation
a useful
or a powerful moral
sort of from a moral philosophy
perspective uh a good thing
i think it is a good thing but before we
ask whether it's a good thing i think
it's it's worth asking whether there's
any way to live without it
the idea of national independence
of a world or a continent which
politically is governed by multiple
independent national states that is a
political theory somebody came up with
that you know in the bible or elsewhere
some someone came up with this idea and
sold it and a lot of people like it
but the nation
is not an invention it it
every place in human history that we
have any record of
there are nations
and
so
the the the
the fact of
people creating families families
creating an alliance uh of of
of of of clans clans creating alliances
of tribes tribes creating alliances of
uh and and
an alliance that becomes the nation we
see that everywhere in human history
everywhere we look
and the love of a group of tribes that
have come together in order to fight
opponents that are trying to destroy
your way of life and you know and
steal your land and and and and harm
your women and children
the the the love of
uh of uh the leadership that brings it
together here this is
you know a george washington type figure
or an alfred the great type figure or or
or saul the biblical saul somebody who
has the the wisdom the daring to unite
the tribes overcome their their you know
their their their internal uh uh mutual
hatreds and grievances and rally them
around a set of ideas a language a
tradition uh a a a a an identity as
people say today that love is eradicable
from human beings maybe we'll have brave
new world people will take drugs in
order to get rid of it the problem is
that could be leveraged by authoritarian
regime yes but that's true of everything
it's like saying you know you can have
children and you can teach them to be
evil you you can make a lot of money you
can use it for evil you you can have a
gun for self-defense but you can use it
for evil come on we just that's that's
that's human that's being human but you
guys are making love this primary which
i don't think it is uh
i know there are lots of people in the
world out there who don't love their
nation because their nation is not worth
loving that is love is conditional it's
not unconditional love is conditioned on
the value that's presented to you you
know so i i lived through this
experience in my own life right i was i
grew up in a in a in in israel
at a time uh of of everything was geared
towards
patriotism and in the state
uh i i would say i was trained to to
when i saw a grenade to jump on it
because that was
you know every song and every story and
everything was about
the state is everything and you should
sacrifice and you know when the flag
went up i got teary-eyed i mean
i bought into it completely
um and at some point i rejected that and
i changed and i changed my alliance and
i i rejected my love of israel it's not
that i don't love it anymore but it's
certainly not my top love and it's
certainly i'm certainly not looking for
the grenade to jump on and i'm not
volunteering to go fight the war there
and and i i fell in love from a distance
with with with the idea of america
i i love the idea of america more than i
love america right and and i could see
myself falling in love out of love with
america given where it's heading right
it's it's not automatic it's it's it's
conditioned on what it is that it
represents and what it is what value it
represents
uh for me
you